امر اخر قد يصب في صاله الهدف الاوكراني
بتحقيق النصر وهو استنزاف القوات الروسيه
لمخزونها من المسيارات الايرانيه التي
تستهلكها بسرعه كبيره معها دراسات الحرب
الامريكي كشف عن ان القوات الروسيه التي
تقاتل في اوكرانيا تحرق بسرعه مخزونها من
الطائرات الايرانيه تحديدا نتحدث عن شاهد
10130 وشاهد 136 مع استمرار المجهود
الحربي واضاف مركز الابحاث في تحليل محدث
امس ان القوات الكرام لان كفت من وتيره
هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار او في انحاء
اوكرانيا منذ ديسمبر ليرفع الضغط عن
طرفانته من الصواريخ ذات التكلفه العاليه
وقتا وشاهدا وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
قال في تغريد على تويتر الجمعه ان القوات
الروسيه استخدمت ما يصل الى 88%
مخزون المسيارات مسيرات شاهد الايرانيه ما
يعني انه سيكون لدى موسكو 90 طائره مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع تحت تصرفها فقط
[موسيقى]
جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
افادت بان الكريم لن يتوقع شحنه اخرى من
طائرات شاهد بدون طيار والتي تم شراءها
سابقا على دفعات تترى واحد بين 200 و300
طائره
اصبحت هجمات مسيرات شاهد سما بارزه في
الجهود الحربيه لموسكو في الاشهر الاخيره
وتم تغيير علامتها التجاريه واطلقت عليها
موسكو اسم غيران اثنين
وسطها كل هذا الضغط والقتال المستعر يشبه
السنتر الامريكي الحرب في اوكرانيا بانها
حرب خنادق بشكل اساسي بل انها تشبه الحرب
العالميه الاولى تقريبا انها مروعه
السيناتور كينج الذي زار اوكرانيا مؤخرا
اضافه ردا على دعوات من بعض الجمهوريين
بخفض بعض التمويل لاكرانيا بالقول انه
سيكون من الكارثي قطعوا المساعدات اكياس
في هذه المرحله وتابعه لوضع الامور في
نصابها بالنسبه للامريكيين يبدو الامر كما
لو ان ساحلنا الشرقيه من فلوريدا ثم غربا
الى يوستنتكساس محتل من قبل قوه اجنبيه
وقد تنتهي الحرب بشيء مختلف تماما عن كل
ما ذكرنا الكلام
لسكرتار مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكسيف دنلوب الذي قال ان
بلاده تلقت عروضا للدخول في تسويه للازمه
الاوكرانيه وفقا لصناريو تسويه الازمه
الكوريه المسؤول الاوكراني اضاف في حديث
تليفزيوني يعرضون علينا تسويه وفقا
للنموذج الكوري اي وفقا لما يسمى بخط
العرض 38 في هذا الطرف يعيش اوكرانيون من
هذا الصنف وهناك يعيش اوكرانيون منصفا اخر
يذكر ان شبه الجزيره الكوريه تقع في حاله
حرب من الناحيه الرسميه وذلك لان الحرب
الكوريه بين الاعوام 1950 و1953 انتهت
بوقف اطلاق النار وليس معاهده سلام تمتد
المنطقه منزوعه السلاح على خط طول العرض
وتقسم شبه الجزيره الكوريه الى جزئين
متساويين تقريبا فهل نرى نسختين من
اوكرانيا غربيه وشرقيه
[موسيقى]